yesterday I wore this my my beloved
reindeer cardigan as you can see I wore
it while I was doing the show and I have
to say that the response to my sweater
was really hurtful and traumatizing
people mocked it relentlessly they said
that it's an old man sweater they said
it makes me look uglier than usual they
said it looks like something an 85 year
old woman stitched together during rec
time at the nursing home someone said my
sweater should be deported to Jupiter
and me along with it well let me tell
you you bullies something all right this
this sweater was made by my grand my
great-grandmother in Ireland and she
gave it to my grandfather before he
emigrated here and he gave it to me two
years before he died so you didn't just
mock my sweater you mocked my family so
I want you to think about it actually I
just made that up my wife got this from
Target I think last year but the point
still stands so in retaliation for the
hateful mockery of my sweater I am
wearing the sweater again and if the
comments continue and the insults
continue I will wear it every day until
Christmas I will keep wearing the
sweater until you all learn some manners
and by the time that you're that I'm
done with this sweater you're gonna be
seeing these reindeers and these weird
shapes I don't even know what this is
supposed to be you're gonna be seeing
them in your nightmares that's how often
I'm gonna wear this sweater now I know
it's kind of weird I guess to wear a
Christmas cardigan out of spite in
retaliation but that's what I'm gonna do
so I really I've really been left with
no choice all right um tumblr the
popular blogging platform says that it
will delete in ban all pornographic
content starting this month according to
Forbes on Monday tumblr announced in a
blog post that adult content will no
longer be allowed here including
explicit sexual content and most cases
of nudity starting in two weeks on the
number 17 any explicit posts on the
platform will be flagged and deleted by
algorithms according to the company the
new adult content guidelines outlined by
tumblr say that the kind of content it's
looking to ban primarily includes photos
videos or gifts not gifs that show
real-life human genitals or female
presenting nipples and any content
including photos videos gifts and
illustrations that depicts sex acts yes
female presenting nipples they can't say
female nipples because that insinuates
that there's some sort of biological
component to sexuality which of course
they can't they couldn't possibly ever
suggest that so female presenting
nipples forbes goes on in the decade or
so since its founding tumblr has served
as a major hub for users and communities
wishing to share adult content via
social media despite periodic pressure
to rein in its content and now it
finally will rein in the content now
this has been this has been met with
outrage by by many tumblr users
apparently who are upset either that
they won't be able to access pornography
on tumblr now or they won't be able to
share it hi this is all news to me I
didn't know that tumblr was porn central
I thought it was just I did I did I
don't even know what tumblr is tumblr
confuses me and I guess that's a sign
that I'm getting old when I'm wearing
cardigans and getting confused by tumblr
but really in all seriousness this is
this is this just shows the problem I
think that parents face because how in
the world do you keep up with this how
do you keep track as a parent of where
your kids are going where kids in
general are going to access this kind of
content now my kids are 5 years old they
don't have access to the Internet so
it's not a concern for me for me yet but
it is a concern for a lot of parents
it's a huge concern how do you control
this how do you stop your kids from
being exposed to this kind of stuff and
what makes this situation even more
difficult is that we as this generation
of parents we're kind of the guinea pigs
right there isn't a lot of history of
parents having to deal with this problem
this this dynamic where
kids from a young age or carrying around
in their pockets
these little devices that can give them
access to everything any information any
image any video and can allow them to
communicate with anyone and even if our
kids aren't carrying around that that
device likely some of their friends will
be carrying around that device so this
is all very new we can't go back and see
how past parental generations dealt with
it because they didn't really have to
deal with it
my parents generation I guess were the
first that had to confront this problem
sort of when the internet became a
household item but for me and my
generation you know we didn't have the
internet until I was in middle school
and smart phones didn't exist so you had
the internet on one computer in the
house and you know you could put the
computer somewhere where the where it
was it was visible and everything and it
was relatively easy to parentally lock
this and that and kind of control things
that way but this is this is just a it's
a whole new ballgame and we need to
figure it out even though we're the
first ones to have to do that
because the stakes are very high and to
highlight just how high the stakes are I
want to call your attention to this a
local news channel in Kansas City KSHB
has a story on their site today and the
story begins Children's Mercy Hospital
Children's Mercy Hospital says they're
seeing a disturbing trend in child
sexual assault cases children are
abusing children Heidi Olson the sexual
assault nurse examiner sane is the
acronym coordinator says I think that
was kind of shocking to us as we were
collecting the data that almost half of
our perpetrators are minors almost half
of the perpetrators are minors the sane
programs data shows perpetrators are
likely to be between 11 and 15 years old
you have 11 year olds who are committing
sexual assaults Jennifer Hansen a child
abuse pediatrician at the hospital says
another thing we're noticing is a lot of
these sexual assaults are
sexual assault so they include physical
violence in addition to sexual violence
last year Children's Mercy saw 444 kids
who were sexually abused within the last
five days that number rounds out to
around a thousand a year when they
include the children who report sexual
assault after five days victims are most
likely to be girls around four to eight
years old the story goes on Hanson Olson
say they're noticing kids are being
exposed to porn at very young ages
around four or five years old they say a
child can develop unrealistic and
dangerous ideas about intimate
relationships by being exposed to
violent graphic porn Hanson says we know
that it's probably multifactorial I
think there are lots of things that
contribute to this but that is the
question how are we as society failing
in such a way that we have 11 12 and 14
year old boys committing violent sexual
assaults another person at the hospital
says what we're seeing is more and more
kids have sexual behavior problems and
more and more kids at the same time have
access to porn pornography is different
today than it used to be so 80% of the
15 most viewed films portray women being
hit spit on kicked called degrading
names etc the kinds of behaviors we
wouldn't want our children or anyone to
engage in alright I mean I think it is
it's clear that's that early exposure to
pornography is very harmful for kids
these are people who have no concept of
human sexuality so I mean four or five
years old
what what if a child is somehow being
exposed to hardcore pornography at the
age of four or five which at that at
that young of an age if that's happening
then that is just pure parental neglect
I mean there's that four or five years
old you should be able to control what
your kid is looking at at that young of
an age and so if they they're if they're
developing a porn habit at that age then
that's just that's just horrible
terrible parenting now as kids get older
it's it's it's a little bit it's going
to be more difficult especially these
days and if the kid goes to school
it's more difficult once you get to be
12 13 14 years old but at that young of
an age and whatever leads to it you've
got a kid that young being exposed to
this kind of stuff what chance do they
have at that point to become
well-rounded healthy individual what
chance does a kid have at the age of
four if a kid at the age of four is
being exposed to pornography what chance
does he have to become a healthy normal
person you know if you have an
eleven-year-old who's committing sexual
assault and they've been looking at porn
since the age of four you how can you
even I don't even know what to say about
it it's just it's so it's so horrific
kids kids at that age they don't have
any defenses against this stuff they
can't filter what they're seeing so
they're learning about sex and love and
romance and all of that stuff from porn
that is going to be that is now for a
lot of these kids their first exposure
to sexuality and to the very concept of
it the idea of it is through hardcore
pornography and we just I don't think we
can even barely wrap our heads around
the the full impact that that's having
on our kids I mean we're seeing this now
you know we're seeing if you have if you
have kids who being exposed to this from
very young ages we see what happens when
they're 11 12 13 14 15 years old but
fast-forward the clock when they're 30
there's probably you know I'm 32 there's
probably not anyone my age or there's to
be very few people my age who were being
exposed to hardcore pornography at you
know when they were 4 or 5 because the
internet hardly existed back then but
you take this generation and then we see
them now what's it gonna be like when
they're when they're grown adult male
it's gonna be like when they're 3035
years old it's just
warps the mind in ways that that we're
only now beginning to to understand so
what can we do about it
you know unfortunately I don't think
that there isn't one single thing there
isn't there isn't a magic switch that we
can flip but I do know that I think
parents have to confront this problem
and the first thing that we should do as
parents is you know keep our kids off of
the internet for as long as humanly
possible you know that they're there
there shouldn't be any concern that oh I
need to make sure my kid has a has a
smartphone because all of his friends
have smartphones and if he doesn't have
one he's gonna be weird like that should
not be our concern at all that our kids
won't have this gadget that everyone
else has in it and they'll be left out
that is a very small price to pay if it
can't if that if taking that simple
measure can in any way protect our kids
from this kind of stuff and from the
long-term effects that it has then it's
a small price to pay so we just I mean
keep your kids off of the the internet
as much as there's there's there's just
no reason why a child needs to have a
smartphone with internet access and as I
said I know that even if you take that
step and they're going to school and
their kids have it and their friends
have smartphones with the internet
access or they're going to their
friend's house and there's a laptop or
whatever you know there's that's the
fact that they don't have a smartphone
isn't going to stop them from being
exposed to something on a different
device but that at least is one simple
step that we can take and I and I cannot
think of any reason I mean these parents
who you know they're nine and ten year
old kids have smartphones with internet
access what's the point look at what
whatever you think your kid's gonna gain
from that whatever advantage your kid is
gonna gain measure that against the
enormous downsides and tell me which
what outweighs what they're I know
parents will say well you know my kid
needs a phone because
if they need to get a hold of me there's
an emergency or something well then fine
they'd you can still did you know you
could still go to the cellphone store
and you could buy a flip phone with no
internet act you can find it you can
still buy an old-fashioned flip phone
they're more durable - on top of it so
then I was likely to break when the kid
drops it get in one of those phones
why does he need a phone that gives him
potentially gives him access to this
whole river of Filth that's what I don't
understand this is something as parents
that we need to start taking seriously
okay another story I wanted to mention a
a 69 year old man from the Netherlands
was told by a court that he could not
legally lower his age by 20 years he
could not a meal rattle bong told The
Washington Post that he feels or that
his feeling about his body in his mind
is that he's about 40 or 45 despite
being born on March 11th 1949 he also
claims that he received a check-up from
a doctor who told him that his
biological age is 45 years rattle bond
said we can make our own decisions if we
want to change our name if we want to
change our gender so I want to change my
age only he was not allowed to do that I
I think he's got a pretty airtight case
based on the the standard modern day
standards he's got a pretty airtight
case if gender is fluid why not age in
fact your age here's the thing your age
is much more fluid than your gender it's
not just that your age is also no your
age actually is in a certain sense fluid
your age is the it it changes for one
thing your age actually does change and
not only that but time itself is
relative just ask Einstein think about
that movie think about the movie the
movie with Matthew McConaughey where he
went into space oh what was that
interstellar right the movie was
massively overrated I thought or-or-or
it was it was it didn't live up to the
to the to the hype I was really looking
forward to it but I was kind of
disappointed I my problem with that
movie is that they sped is like a thigh
our movie and four of the hours were
spent on earth and then they went into
space and they were back in 22 seconds
and so it just was anyway but you think
about that movie Matthew McConaughey
there's that scene where he goes to
another planet and the planet with the
really big waves and they're down on the
planet for just a few minutes
but then they come back and they go back
home and they hook up with the space
station and he finds that his daughter
is now an 80 year old woman so even
though he aged only a few days his
daughter aged like 50 or 60 years so
mr.radha bond could easily make the case
that he is only 69 years old on earth
with our gravity and with the speed that
our planet happens to be moving around
the Sun etc if he were to have been born
on a different planet or if he was born
and then he had moved to a different
planet for a few years his age would be
completely different
so that's ages is actually relative it's
it is a fluid relative concept not only
that but it's also true that we age at
different rates biologically so there is
some there is some truth to saying that
a 69 year old man might be biologically
45 in the sense that his age hasn't
taken the physical toll on him that it
has for most people who were born around
the time that he was and also it's true
that mr. Ragno bond while he isn't now
45 he was 45 once so he has at least
experienced he has had the experience of
being 45 the significance of that is he
knows what 45 feels like because he was
45 so when he says I feel like I'm 45 he
has a frame of reference he has
something to compare it to he can he can
think back to when he was 45 and he
could say yeah I feel like that you know
my feelings have I have that feeling of
being 45 so there is some sense to that
like it does make a certain amount of
sense all of these cases all of these
points rather I think make the case for
the fluidity of gender much
stronger than the fluidity of gender or
I'm sorry that the fluidity of age the
case for the fluidity of age is much
stronger than the case for the fluidity
of gender your gender your sex is a
fixed thing so if you're a man you've
always been a man and you would be a man
anywhere in the universe like it doesn't
matter where you go you can go to the
Matthew McConaughey planet with the big
waves and you would still be a man
anywhere you go at any point you're a
man whereas that's not the case with
with age so we may look at something
like this a case like this and we say oh
it's a slippery slope you know we we
we've accepted this idea of gender being
fluid and now the next step is people
are gonna say that age is fluid and race
is fluid and so on and so forth no
that's see that's not exactly right
because when it comes to making things
fluid and if we're on a slope right
actually you know gender the fluidity of
gender is down here on the slope but age
and race they're up there further up on
the slope so another way of putting it
is to say that race is fluid or age is
fluid that isn't crazier than saying
that gender is fluid that's actually a
little bit less crazy so the point I
always make about the slippery slope is
that it's not actually a slope but it's
more like we just as a culture we went
into freefall and there was no slope at
all we just plunged into the abyss of
insanity and and along the way we
actually skipped over a few steps if we
were following a logical slope if we
were following sort of a logical
cultural regression we would have began
by saying oh race is fluid you could be
whatever race you want and then we would
have said oh you know what actually age
is fluid - and then after years we would
have said oh maybe gender is fluid also
but we skipped ahead to the craziest
thing and now we're
backtracking and covering all the bases
we skipped over because even something
like race yet again race actually you
can be multiple different races you know
that's possible race actually is a a
fluid thing there's probably there is
not one single person on earth who's
just one race and that's it we all we're
all a mixture of various different
things so even that again that makes
more sense then just to say that gender
is fluid or that you can change your
gender we we skipped ahead to the to the
to the craziest thing that's what we did
and that's what we do with that's what
we've been doing in general in our
cultures we have been you know the left
I think that tells you something about
the the victories that the left has
achieved where they have not gone slowly
and incrementally they went right for
the you know they went right for the
gold as far as they're concerned they
weren't interested in any kind of
incremental steps to get them where they
wanted to be they went right for you
know they went right for let's make
gender fluid and they achieved it and
now that they have there's just no way
to argue with someone who says yeah you
know what I'm 69 technically but I feel
like I'm forty five so I'm gonna be 45
there's just there's just no way to
argue with them um speaking of crazy and
then there's this an all-male a capella
group at Princeton will no longer
perform the song kiss the girl from The
Little Mermaid because the song delivers
a problematic message about consent
now this concern was first raised by an
editorial in the school's newspaper The
Daily Princetonian the article now just
before I read some of this this article
is not I don't think this article is
satire this is this is totally serious
okay the article says even when gently
crooned by an animated crab the song
kissed the girl from the Disney hit The
Little Mermaid is more misogynistic and
dismissive of a consent than it is cute
by performing the song multiple times
semester the tiger tones elevated to an
offensive and violating ritual no matter
how great the tradition this canonical
Tiger tones tune should be struck from
their repertoire it's its lyrics raise
some serious issues the premise of the
song originally sung in the Disney film
The Little Mermaid is that the male
Prince Erik on a beautiful on a date
with the beautiful female Ariel should
kiss her without asking for a single
word to affirm her consent despite the
fact that an evil sea witch cursed
Ariel's voice taking it away making
verbal consent impossible the song is
clearly problematic from the get-go
removed from its cushioning context of
mermaids magic and PG ratings the
message comes across as even more
jarring lyrics such as it's possible she
wants you to there's one way to ask her
it don't take a word not a single word
go on and kiss the girl kiss the girl
and she won't say a word until you
kissed that girl unambiguously
encouraging men to make physical
advances on women without obtaining
clear consent the song launches a
heteronormative attack on women's rights
to oppose the romantic and sexual
liberties taken by men further
inundating the listener with themes of
toxic masculinity in trying to motivate
Erik to kiss to kiss
Ariel the crab Sebastian makes use of
lines such as looks like the boys too
shy don't be scared and it's such a say
a shame too bad you're gonna miss the
girl such expressions imply that not
using aggressive physical action to
secure areal sexual submission makes
Erik weak an irrefutable scaredy-cat
this this is this is like something that
I would write as satire only it's way
better and this is what makes satire
impossible now because I couldn't that's
how I could not I couldn't write
anything for I don't think anyone could
write anything funnier than that if you
wanted to make fun of the left hyper
politically correct
point of view you you you couldn't write
anything more hilarious than what I just
read only that's completely real and it
doesn't even make any sense
because from what I remember of that
scene the crab is is on aerial side
right like the correct the crab is kind
of speaking for aerial and trying to
entice the man to kiss her
so actually look I agree that the song
and and indeed the movie raise serious
concerns about consent but it isn't
Ariel's consent being violated
think about it Ariel is a is a half
human ocean creature she uses a magic
spell to become human so that she can
seduce this hapless innocent prince who
has no idea what's going on she never
once informs him that she's a sea
creature she never gives him the
opportunity to consent to being in this
beastial relationship an uninformed
consent is not consent and I submit that
a man has the right to know if he is
romantically involved with a squid okay
he has the right no this this is serious
I'm not this is not a laughing matter
put yourself in Eric's position you know
imagine that you just met a woman and
things are going well and and they're
getting serious and you're contemplating
marriage and then one Saturday afternoon
you say to this to this woman who you
just found wandering on a beach randomly
and that and that never would never
occurred to you to think there's
anything strange about that and then but
it doesn't matter and so one Saturday
afternoon you say to your you say to her
hey let's go for a date at the aquarium
and she's a little bit hesitant and you
don't understand why but she says okay
let's go and then you're walking by the
dolphin exhibit and suddenly she goes oh
hi mom and dad and you say what your
parents are aquatic animals you didn't
mention that on your match.com profile
and then she goes on to explain that she
really lives in the ocean and she's
actually a fish and an evil octopus cast
a spell so that she could come on land
and coerce you into bestiality how would
that make you feel so who's the real
victim here who's
is actually being violated that's my
question you know if we're going to be
offended by this song we should be
offended in the right way and when you
think about it in this way this song and
the whole movie is tere it's horrifying
it is all about a deceitful sea monster
trying to seduce a human man and lure
him into the depths of the ocean to
engage in all manner of debauchery
pretty it's pretty chilling actually
when you think about it so I think that
you know Princeton is on to something
here but they they just they're looking
at it from the wrong angle in my opinion
all right we'll leave it there thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed